welcome to our Utah adventures we are
about two hours into our road trip and
we're on our way to not sure where we're
going I think we're going to grace
that's second Yin just kidding we're not
sure where we're going but I'm glad
we're going right now
it's okay well I think I don't know much
chocolate salted caramel in my coffee
at the station when I was thinking what
we need this trip I was actually gonna
say she would get a selfie stick I'm not
proud of it but we actually might need
it should we get it just in case I get
sick get the second get the sec okay ii
think clock let's also get some nuts so
you guys have never used swarm it's an
application that used to be a part of
Foursquare but it broke off into its own
separate app where you can check in a
different locations so I just checked
into these Travel Plaza and there is a
petting zoo right next door and the
babies the baby zebra could be a girl
uber mmm true but it also said that the
petting zoo is very nice
and they hope that it continues to grow
there it is guys look at that
the Bears willow do you get the animals
in there
we've been driving for about three hours
now and we just stopped to our first
little destination we're gonna grab
lunch and then head up to the canyon
this is the chuck wagon general store
it's a bakery snack bar they've got
fresh produce and meats Sporting Goods
ice film beer laundromat video rentals
what kind of videos do you have sir
Pascal says very laid-back place a
stone's throw away from Capitol Reef and
Pete I like it
great check in pesco great check
we're here Jenna Jenna
do you like it I'm the application
okay do you like I like pepper jack
cheese what's it like to be vegetarian
that doesn't eat vegetables vegetables I
do not know
right now
oh so this is a tiny little schoolhouse
that they used to have little gatherings
ATS it's the town of fruta it's so
little - it's a little bit little tiny
desk smelly truck
look at this can you believe it now
officially embrace Canyon and it started
to rain a little while ago but we got
coffee
we got camo ponchos which we're not
wearing right now so probably gonna go
take a little peek at this little
lookout points and then we're gonna go
do a little vehicle tour and possibly a
hike at the end we'll see how the
weather is
but gentleman back there on our phone
look at you girl look at you girl
shaking that Oh rainy probably should
about the poncho
squad up on a Tuesday it is actually
Tuesday today yeah
probably when I post this video it won't
be Tuesday you love our camo
we just have to have we're at pizza and
noodle company in Springdale we just
drove through Zions National Park and
we're gonna be hiking there tomorrow so
I'm really excited about that but right
now we're gonna get some food and then
go to the hotel oh yeah this day isn't
so amazing everywhere you look it's just
absolutely beautiful it's like it's not
even real see you guys tomorrow for
elephants smells like delicious
plastic